là aujourd'hui en faire ce soir vous
nous annoncez 3500 euros
clairement il ya un très gros écart pour
les petits commerçants la pilule reste
toujours amer comme ses collègues le
renvoi basse qui attendaient beaucoup du
dernier comité syndical qui devait
revoir les bases minimum pour le calcul
de la cotisation foncière des
entreprises cotisations qui pour
certains ont augmenté de 500% en un an
comme c'est le cas pour cet agent
immobilier qui a payé 307 euros en 2011
et devaient s'acquitter de 1694 euros en
2012 les bases ont donc été revus une
nouvelle tranche créé pour 2013 les
basses passe de 2000 à 1500 euros pour
les chiffres d'affaires de moins de cent
mille euros et de 6 mille à trois mille
cinq cents euros pour les chiffres
d'affaires supérieur à 100 milles
l'annoncé qui a été faite de passer donc
pour les entreprises qui ont un chiffre
d'affaires supérieur à 100 mille euros
le faire passer au curseur de
3500 lieu de 6000 certes mais surtout au
lieu de 1093 de l'année dernière ça ne
représente malgré tout toujours une
augmentation de 350 % mardi 11 décembre
nous avons rencontré monsieur cadalbert
suite à une à dire un rassemblement
manifestation nous avons fait lui nous
avait annoncé que le curseur sur les mii
aux allant aux environs de 2000 qu'on
lui a fait préciser plusieurs fois
volontairement de telle façon que le
chiffre soit bien donner cet agent
immobilier par le même de trahisons les
mots sont forts mais la colère est là au
sein de son association il a déjà
enregistré une cinquantaine d'adhésion
et affirment rester mobilisés en 2013
de même pour les confédérations ont
demandé qu'il y ait un geste sur la sncf
il est fait bon malheureusement il est
clair que les tpe les pme considèrent
qu' on peine encore trop puisque
certains d'entre elles payent plus que
200 250 % malgré la baisse des des
montants côté indiqué aujourd'hui donc
on aurait préféré que ça y est un petit
peu plus loin
aujourd'hui on a une contribution qui
est en dessous de la moyenne du
département des yvelines
ce qui est important et quand on
rapporte cette contribution au aux
effets du développement de la ville
nouvelle ce qui leur permet d'avoir
leurs activités d'entreprises dans la
ville nouvelle c'est effectivement une
contribution qui est à la hauteur de ce
qu'apporte la ville nouvelle à toute
cette entreprise on demande instamment
que ces deux lois doit re changé et en
particulier qui soit basée sur
les valeurs ajoutées sur les bénéfices
et pas sur le chiffre d'affaires qui a
pas grand chose à dire donc encore une
fois c'est une loi injuste mal foutu et
qu'effectivement il va falloir revoir
dans ce sens une motion a été ajoutée en
fin de débat pour demander que le taux
d'effort ne se basent plus sur le
chiffre d'affaires mais sur la valeur
ajoutée ou le bénéfice net de
l'entreprise
les commerçants de manille de leur côté
se réuniront en assemblée générale en
janvier prochain pour définir la suite
de leur mouvement